it's great to have bill scher back on
the program he's the contributing editor
to Politico magazine he is also host of
the new books in politics podcast it's
part of the new books Network and I mean
bill listen I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
I'm scared about the midterms
I saw unheralded on previously for a
long time unseen levels of enthusiasm
early in Trump's first term my feeling
anecdotally is that some of that
excitement has waned we've got a new PR
RI poll which says only 28% of young
adults are certain they're going to vote
in 2018 is my fear warranted at this
point well they're you know there's
healthy fear and there's paralyzing fear
it's good to have a healthy fear yeah
I'm not paranoid but yeah yeah you don't
get cocky you don't assume that
everything is just gonna fall into place
and it's it's preordained the Democrats
take back the house that's not useful
the evidence so far I mean there there's
a debate whether you should look at
polling more or special election
performance more mmm you know all the
special elections we've had up to now
have shown you know Democratic over
performance and Republican under
performance there's definitely more
enthusiasm on the Democratic side of the
coin and you can I think a fair
assumption would be Democrats are
obviously a highly outraged what's going
on with Trump so they're motivated to
turnout Republicans you part of Trump's
victory was premise taun Trump only
voters voters that came out for him and
if he's not on the ballot there's gonna
be an enthusiasm drop on their side
similar to what happened with Obama in
his presidency when he wasn't on the
ballot Democratic turnout was lower so I
just look there's a lot of positive
signs in that regard at least in terms
of the house that doesn't necessarily
translate to the Senate because there's
so much Democratic turf being defended
especially in states that Trump won
which makes that much more uphill for
Democrats so the likeliest scenario is
Democratic House Democratic House
Republicans said they could even go in
opposite directions Democrats gained
scenes in the house and lose seats in
the Senate so
let's take those sort of in two parts I
mean number one the enthusiasm that you
rightly identify and the anger I feel
like is waning not necessarily because
people are forgetting or don't care but
because of the hyper normalization
that's going on every week there's five
scandals new lows in lack of decorum and
geopolitical diplomacy and and norms
people are becoming desensitized to I
mean III obviously happening to me
because I talk about this stuff every
day
but even other people every new scandal
is sort of like yeah what's one more
scandal at this point and that really is
concerning to me it's something to be
aware of you don't want to become
complacent but I sighs haven't seen
evidence on the ground mean the primary
turnout in every Democratic contest has
been very high now that's not just Trump
that's also many competitive races if
you have if there's a sense that a race
is not preordained you're more likely to
show up but if you're in a district that
has always been a fait accompli for
Republicans to win and I have seven
Democrats running in that district and
so you show up to see who's the
Democrats going to be that shows
evidence of interest and we haven't seen
that kind of drop-off in the actual
primary now we're in a period right now
in July where there's a bit of a primary
low we had a bunch in you know May and
June there's not as many this month that
starts to kick up again in August and
September then you're into the general
election period so you just may be
feeling some summer doldrums are gonna
start kicking in once we get to the fall
what about the special election so I go
back and forth on this I think that you
can find data to get excited about in
the special elections and you can find
data like for example that even when in
Alabama Republicans ran a serial accused
child sexual assault or Democrats only
barely won in what yes is a very very
red red state and I'm just not totally
sure how to parse the special election
results well I would look at it a
different way when Doug Jones beat Roy
Moore people treated at the time as well
the guy
accuse sex offender a child molester so
that that doesn't give you any kind of
insight into what's gonna happen in
others racism states yeah
but then a couple months later Connor
Lam wins in western Pennsylvania where
there was no scandal involving the
Republican candidate this is also very
this was an as read an area as Alabama
but still pretty read Trump did very
well there and the candidate ran they
tried the time to really push tax cuts
as a saving grace there's only a few
months after the tax cut bill passed and
that proved not to be a saving grace
even though it's Connor Lam was critical
of it he still was able to to win that
race so I don't think we have a
situation where Democrats are winning
for fluky reasons I think there's a
general pattern of Democratic Democratic
base is being excited and Republican
bases being deflated relatively speaking
that there's tough see dire Trump
loyalists out there but Trump just
barely won with not just his diehard
support but also more marginal soft
support and those folks seem to not be
showing up for these early special
elections and we'll see what happens in
November but that's the pattern so far
in terms of what's riding on this I am
very concerned about net neutrality I'm
concerned about more Supreme Court
justice selections I think it's almost a
foregone conclusion that if Republicans
control the House and Senate after the
midterms that it doesn't matter what
Moeller finds it's just nothing
nothing's going to happen
what do you identify as the areas where
the the the most is riding on this
midterm election
well if Democrats can take the house
then you're going to stymie anymore
Trump legislation you're not gonna have
another big tax cut you're you're not
gonna build the wall but the Senate is
obviously the tougher road but without
Democrats controlling the Senate you
can't block judges so you know I agree
with you bread Cavanaugh you seem to be
implying Brookhaven is probably again
that on the court I think it's probably
correct there's no evidence that a see
Collins or Lisa Murkowski is gonna jump
ship right ah and if they don't jump
ship you're probably going to see Joe
Manchin Heidi Heitkamp John tester Joe
Donnelly Doug Jones those people are
probably gonna vote for Kavanagh knowing
this is already a done deal it's it's
kind of a free vote I'm not the person
who's deciding he's gonna be on the
court so I might look at some bipartisan
points for jumping on the bandwagon that
might make some Democrats really angry
that the Democrats instead it could be
United but what you really don't want is
for tester I can't Manchin Donnelly you
know what those guys to lose in November
because you're if you're ever gonna stop
anymore Trump judges you need those guys
in the Senate and getting a few more on
top of that so I don't think it's a I
wouldn't give high odds and ever guys
taking this in it but it's not
implausible and usually if you care
about judges you want to make sure
you're picking up seats in the Senate if
at all possible one of the criticisms
when looking at some of the races you
talked about but then also some of the
races that have different dynamics and I
hear this criticism from people who are
to the left of the Democratic Party
and also to right-wingers they write to
me and they say David what are Democrats
running on like what what is the
Democratic platform for the midterms and
my instinctual reaction is that there
doesn't necessarily have to be such a
defined
party platform because we're talking
about state-level races and the dynamics
of the those races sort of differ two
questions to you number one is there
some broader Democratic platform that is
visible across the candidates in the
2018 midterms and number two is it
actually necessary or are these really
all different races with different
dynamics well they're definitely
different races different dynamics there
is an attempt at a national platform led
by Chuck Schumer called a better deal mm
I don't think you're seeing a whole lot
I like you're seeing consensus around
candidates embracing that or even using
the language and let's face it there is
there are divides in the Democratic
Party
so some candidates we're winning
primaries are more quote unquote
establishment and doing things along the
lines of let's fix the Affordable Care
Act let's invest in infrastructure
things that are left of center but
relatively safe positions to take then
of course you have people who are more
economically populist or Bernie Kratt or
Democratic socialists like Alexander
Kaiser of Cortez the most obvious
example there's also Kerry Eastman in
Omaha in Nebraska second the Omaha area
these are folks are more Pro
single-payer some are saying abolish ice
some are talking about your more you
know widespread free College things
things like that that are not
necessarily blessed by Democratic HQ in
Washington so whatever you or I think is
the right thing to do what's the best
are the briquettes the fact is people
are gonna run differently in different
races probably because of the terrain
involved probably because of who wins
these primaries and I don't think it's
gonna be the billeting for Democrats in
November because most people are gonna
come out in opposition to incumbent
Republicans and not worry so much about
differs amongst Democrats when you get
to 2020 which is gonna start happening
as soon as the 2010 midterms are over
all this litigation is gonna is gonna
really escalate who had the better idea
in the midterms which candidates you
know if Cary Eastern wins in Nebraska
you got a strong argument that a single
player can win in Nebraska we should run
this across the board if the more
establishment up candidates are winning
in the swing areas those posts are gonna
say look a Kaiser Cortes is great in
Bronx and queens that's not what we need
in Ohio in Montana and Missouri so we
got to watch closely to see how all
these people do come November in the
meantime you're gonna get used to
differences of opinion at differences in
strategy yeah you mentioned a couple of
times there Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
from the New York 14th district who
defeated the incumbent Democrat who I
believe didn't even show up to debate
her how
or let me put a different way what can
we draw more generally from the results
of that primary and what does that
primary not tell us about the broader
direction of Democrats in 2018 I think
what you can draw from it is that there
is a vibrant democratic socialist
faction that has made significant
inroads into the Democratic Party okay
now stop right there before you we got
to clarify this because this has been a
point of such confusion when you say
Democratic Socialist do you mean
socialist in terms of socializing the
means of production or do you mean
social democracy in the mode of Sweden
because even they seem confused about
what they mean by it yeah I don't know
if I can even despite that I think
there's a debate going on within
socialist circles what the definition of
socialism means okay which is which has
been going on you for a century yeah
it's kicking up anew so much drived
Democratic Socialist whatever it is they
mean by it that's all I can say about it
I'm excusing their language and there is
a democratic solutions of America they
are endorsing candidates a handful those
candidates are winning places yeah
that's a hell of a lot better than they
were doing you know one year or two
years ago right so you have to
acknowledge like you know you know
they're here and there and they're
kicking up some dust you can't say just
because our Kaiser Court has won a low
turnout primary in a very very blue
district that Democratic socialists are
taking over the entirety of the
Democratic Party that this is a winning
message in swing area it does it just
has something to say about that yes it's
the same day that she won in upstate New
York in a more conservative district
Antonio Delgado won his primary he's a
corporate attorney and he did not run on
a Bernie clap burning crab platform and
he beat people who were in Maryland six
rural suburban district David trone
who's a multi-millionaire wine mogul he
beats someone running on a single-payer
platform and you go back to other races
the famous Texas seven where the
d-triple-c you know with nuclear on
Laura Moser dropping Oppo research are
during the primary people went ballistic
how dare the Democrats do this obviously
gonna backfire against them she made the
runoff then she got trounced in the in
the runoff against another corporate
attorney
I mean she's not running as a right
winger she's running left-of-center but
she wasn't running a populist campaign
this is an upscale Houston suburb my
only point is is that different kinds of
people are winning in different
districts yeah and like I said you know
it's not just orchids because in deep
blue Bronx and queens you have care
Eastman and suburban Omaha so I'm not
saying the left isn't winning any other
places but it's in primaries so we need
to see how well these folks do in the
general or Kaiser Court is winning where
she wanted to tell anything about who's
gonna win in a swing area in the general
you and I have spoken before about what
may not be winning issues for Democrats
and you've even gone so far as to
sometimes talk about like losing issues
for Democrats a couple I want to sort of
just run by you are number one
debt and deficit at this point
particularly because it's not Trump that
they are running against at least not
directly
I spoke to Mitt Romney's opponent
earlier this week and she's talking a
lot about debt and deficit and I just am
unsure that that that's a really a
winning issue at this point in this
particular climate for Democrats number
two after the sort of activism from the
Florida parkland students around guns
has started to sort of fade you're not
hearing that much nationally about guns
although it is playing a role at sort of
the more local level can you comment on
debt and guns and then if you think that
there are issues Democrats it should
stay away from right now you know damn
deficit are always very tempting for
Democrats to pursue when Republicans are
in power because Republicans are often
hypocrites they can play about epidemics
and when Democrats are in charge they
get in power and they weren't up the
deficit so it's very tempting to say
look at those folks they don't mean what
they say but you got to be careful about
that because if you're that implying put
me in charge and I will tame
denne deficit well you might be you know
tying your own hands exactly about what
you can do once you get in charge it's
possible that it is a perfectly fine
electoral message it's not gonna fire up
the bass but to the extent you're trying
to win in swing areas and pick off right
leading swing voters it may well be a
useful message to use but you gotta be
extraordinarily careful of how you use
it because you don't want to shut off a
policy avenues that you want to pursue
what you get into power bill scher
contributing editor to Politico magazine
host of the new books in politics
podcast that's part of the new books
Network bill pleasure as always
thank you